hi I'm Ryan right and i'm gerry and i'm
michelle q welcome to reason to see
where we give you reasons to see and not
to see mama mama so let's hang out
Ryan's consensus there are a lot of
reasons to see mama there are a lot of
reasons to see mama there are a lot of
reasons to see mom Jerry's consensus
there are some strong reasons to see
mama there are some strong reasons to
see mama Michelle's consensus there are
a lot of reasons to see mama there are a
lot of reasons to see mama reason to see
number one the horror this film did
scare me a lot I was very scared
throughout a good amount of it it's not
consistently scary it's mainly jump
scares i would say it's definitely got a
creepy vibe and a cool sort of gear
dienes about it which which I really
like as far as scares go there are some
there are a couple really good jump
scares that I jumped and was like god I
thought mama was pretty scary and I
liked how you actually see mama early on
like they establish that no it's a ghost
guys and there are times where it's
scary whether or not even really trying
to be scary it's scary but it's also
kind of funny at the same time like
there's a certain type of enthusiasm to
the scares that I really enjoyed it's
weird I've never cared so much about
children before that also scared the
living [ __ ] at me I like that they had
that intro because it immediately
establishes sympathy and humanity for
these kids before it turns them into
complete animals yeah because we're not
makes that possible and their
animalistic qualities actually make
sense to the story makes sense the way
they move it's not like they're just
weird supernatural freaky little kids
based off their upbringing based off who
they who's been raising them it actually
makes perfect sense of what's going on
yeah and why they
way they need it out yeah cuz they move
like creepy little [ __ ] it's almost
like an animal packed it's kind of a
fantasy type of horror at the same time
you can almost call it the legend of
mama it's a total fairy tale I mean jump
scares you know I mean people call that
cheap because it doesn't stick like
anyone can make somebody jump by making
loud sounds and cutting to something so
I get why people complain but at the
same time it's a component of horror and
it serves its purpose and as it stands
this is a movie that's like a jump-scare
around every corner like there is some
suspense and like I said part of the
horror that I enjoyed the most in this
is all the eerie sort of creepy stuff
jump scares are usually backed up with
some type of creepy visual at the same
time the fear is very menacing
throughout the whole entire movie
there's this threat of when is mommy
going to come out what's mom I'm gonna
do next and which side are these
children horn or the children for you
know Annabella Luke or are they for Mama
what's gonna happen with them are they
kind of doing some type of manipulation
reason to see number two the directing
and the writing it's rare where you get
a horror movie that is so
character-based every character in this
film I thought was fully fleshed out
from Jessica Chastain to Luke to the
little girls i like how Annabelle and
Luke have this real relationship that's
going on where Luke is so focused on
doing this for the children and try to
find these kids see what's up man
Annabelle is kind of distancing herself
from the relationship and she wants to
be leader on type of life in she's
constantly being thrown into these
situations and with a fairytale aspect
it's almost like it was fate for her to
be put into the situation because it's
movie in a lot of ways you could almost
call it a psychological horror film at
times as well because they they there's
a lot of psychology they infuse into a
ghost story which you don't often see
you usually got some type of paranormal
expert that comes along this time it's
like no they got a psychologist expert
who comes along the story is kind of
familiar but I thought they did a kind
of a fresh take on it you know bringing
the fairy tale elements into it and not
just making it like some long drawn-out
tension-filled because there's a lot of
different layers in it sometimes it's
just dramatic sometimes
emotional sometimes it's scary sometimes
it feels like a fantasy you know they
got a lot of different themes going on
and the director Andre muschietti
something like that he never pronounced
a guy's last name or his first name I
always get it wrong you know like a lot
of people are looking at guillermo del
toro but i feel a lot of the credit
actually goes to him because he's a
whole story trader of it he's the
co-writer he's the director it's this is
really his film and he did an excellent
job at it you know it definitely has del
toro horror fantasy stamp on it you can
see why he presented this movie yeah and
there's a ton of Spanish crew it's also
yeah you definitely got to give Andre
muschietti credit because even if the
script isn't fully up to it the
direction is like it's really well
directed moving it makes you excited to
see what he's gonna do next you know I
adore the ending of it in some ways it
really actually brought to mind um the
legend of La Llorona I didn't even yeah
that's I mean there's something like
there's some homage aspects going on in
this film that I really do enjoy some
people are calling this like confusing
and hard to follow but I don't really
think it is confusing and hard to follow
you know main stories there are some
things in the third act or where I felt
like something had been cut out or
missing it's like why does everybody
leave at like 530 when it's gonna be
doing it always made sense why they went
there and what they did but the thing
that never made sense is why are you
going so late at night reason to see
number three cinematography the
cinematography was beautiful look yet
from the beginning of the movie you know
like that oh just that moment where
those children are sitting by the fire
in the cabin and it mama rolls the
cherry to them is from that moment I was
like wow what beautiful cinematography
we're looking at right now well they
played a lot of color and stuff like
that like you notice the color balances
on each on a lot of the scenes change
from like blues to golds to these River
Range
yeah there are some really stylized
moments that are that are really cool
you know like I saw the shortest movies
based on and do clearly knows what he's
doing with imagery and this movie takes
that to another level in a really cool
way the cinematography enhances the
creepy aspect and enhances the fantasy
aspect every single type of genre theme
they're going for the cinematographer
and the director really seemed to be on
the same level to what they were trying
to achieve with not just the look with
the tone it just mailed the tone down
reason to see number four great
performances I have to start off with
talking about those two little kids yeah
i mean if nothing else yeah you have to
mention them you're compassionate for
them when the director wants to be
compassionate for them and they scare
that [ __ ] out of you who and the rector
wants you to be scared shitless from
them they're great they're there believe
I could have bought them as like they
cast two real sisters together yeah I
mean they pull some incredible
performances out of them and you know
for such young ages and I mean that goes
on on on them and working with the
director I imagine because you know I'm
sure they didn't put them in all those
scary situations necessarily but it
really comes across and they dare
fantastic because like when when lily is
being a young child it's believable it
isn't and then when she's also being you
know showing more for traumatized sides
and her fearful sides that that's also
believable and when she's being a creepy
little [ __ ] it's also but we don't know
you know what I mean yeah and same thing
with Victoria when she's this girl with
at that age with that kind of level of
confusion and trauma like wow the the
emotion emitted from them is so
believable both those girls without
those two girls this movie would not
have been as believable yeah definitely
and it's great performances throughout
not just her you know Jessica Chastain
who is solid and zero dark thirty and
she's she's great again I like to think
of this is the sequel to zero yeah so
what did she does it afterwards if she
goes home starts a bad
Kaiser hair really goes all out I love
that look on her know she I'm just gonna
say Ted it up punk chick is ya know
Jessica Chastain that's what's up
actually believable in it cuz you know
the last movie ice song upper was your
car 30 and then I see this and very
believable very very different and yet
she's subtle but you don't really
realize how great of a performance she
actually does in this movie till you
reflect that on the film I could also be
about her in a way you know like the
reference that the title can be tipped
towards her as well you're not but yeah
becoming a mom kind of taps into her
maternal instincts and the guy play
Luke's he's really getting it to you
know he's not one of the standout
performances but he's a good he is a
really sympathetic role in it I mean
he's got a motive and the psychologist
too is also solid as well yeah you know
he managed to be if he fit though the
genre of this film just right because
he's not like a creepy psychologist
although at times he's a little bit
creepy he's not creepy but it but you
you have to wonder what his intent is
with all this yeah you know is he is he
kind of greedy about it as you really
care was also very believable just just
threw out split decisions visual effects
now mama was very visual effects and
Mama scared me like as far as mama goes
she scared the crap out of me with the
cinematography working with the visual
effects I thought that made her look
that much more real and believable to me
had a fantasy aspect to it so I actually
really enjoyed the visual effects on her
and I don't think if the visual effects
were as good on her I don't think I
would have been as scared of her I'd go
back and forth because there are times I
think she looks good in this movie and
then there are times where I'm a little
distracted by like that's a CG creature
would it pull you out well you know the
fact i was saying they're noticing it
was kind of a pullout I mean it didn't
it didn't keep me from enjoying the film
overall cuz i really enjoyed it I saw
the short and the way they look make
mama look in the short is entirely like
like unnerving and this was a little
more flowy and ethereal and still
sinister but there were certain moments
that didn't feel like they absolutely
needed a BCG I there were times where it
it felt a parent's that it I was
watching a CG creation see I was never
fully ever pulled out by it no I
actually really liked that aspect of her
because it making it seem more mythical
it kind of like pulls you out of the
sense that it's not super real because
usually with like when it comes to
paranormal movies I get freaked the [ __ ]
out like I cannot watch it because I'm
so scared it's gonna happen to me in
this situation she was very scary she
was menacing but the same time the fact
of how she looked made it seem like
scary within the realms of the movie but
I really like that and actually that
really reminded me of the type of
portrayal of the supernatural in the
orphanage I think she's still really
creepy and her movements and even though
she might have looked a little cg esque
it really did it for me it didn't pull
me out in movie I really bother me much
like oh I wish they'd made her morse you
know realistic-looking I think it really
gave the right tone to move you
personally it's fair I think it I think
also partly it's I feel like it kind of
takes away from what stuff they may have
done practically that then doesn't look
quite real because of that like it's
sort of a blend like I'm all for mixing
CGI and practical like I'm down with
that it's just there there were certain
times or I wasn't entirely convinced by
what i was looking at I guess but really
like is that I felt like the effects of
it because it looked uh sometimes very
CGI to me I felt it blended in with a
realm so well that it actually enhanced
it more because I don't know what it
ghost looks like
I have no idea but I imagine it looks
kind of surreal it looks a little bit
like whoa what that doesn't look real to
me you know what I mean yeah I'm because
it it looks unnatural and it looks like
things ought not to look hmm and I'm all
for that conceptually I'm just saying I
didn't fully I wasn't like that's a
killer effects job when I when I left
the movie I was like there were some
times where I really like the effect
there were some times where I was kind
of like oh you know I wasn't fully sold
by what they do with the effect huh
that's why the split decision to each
their own
hey subscribe subscribe or else Mama's
gonna come and eat you yeah subscribe
and these and subscribe
you